gives up the dribble and it goes up over
the top
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we'll be back the chasm have almost
doubled being at the free-throw line
[Applause]
with the nasty left hand finish varies
the acceptance rate turning the corner
gets inside and finishes with the
two-hand slam headed strong minutes left
in this game a lot of time left
[Applause]
filthy left hand slam for tsunami
poverty feet and beyond last year which
is an NBA record and he did so it at 35
point line is you still have to make the
basket you got to make the basket and
that's the tremendous fast it throws it
around the back of theis around the
corner goes those drums
quick dump the left hand
I mean is there EZ Pass Carter he's
already met a tear that's time that
shock folks begging loose ball picked up
by bridges he spent a half-step quicker
than going up look at that Kelly your
brains been a happy one higher than
everyone else after the yelling of a
junior shot true turns it up on the run
out it's going to be counting your
breath and the slab for obray points off
a take away whose brain all the way to
the bucket
[Applause]
7o run by Phoenix ribbon hooker on the
benches five fouls
the lane opens up and tsunami poppy
wattles it down with the left hand
lasers cut into what was once a 16-point
[Applause]
stealing left hand
thunderjam first two for Monte Morris
off the Denver bench
Kelly head down goes for the crush even
white on top of Plumlee he was not gonna
let Plumlee block that shot Ellie a
grade junior detonated in Denver
[Music]